hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round nine of the
lindoris abbey rapid challenge uh a
tactical brilliancy if you will but
before we check out the game
i would just like to make a short
announcement uh it's friday again and
we're gonna have a nice
arena uh and i'm gonna be streaming it
so the links to the to both tournaments
are in the description below as usual
so do join and i will be seeing you
later now getting back to the game
nakamura with the white pieces faces
polish number one young shisht of duda
and nakamura opens with e4 we have c5 by
duda
the sicilian defense we have knight to
f3 d6 and now bishop to b5 chair going
for the canal attack
and knight the d7 defending and it's
really important for duda to do well as
he is on the verge of dropping out
of the competition uh before the the
knockout phase even uh begins
uh and here uh the most often played
moves are castles and d4 but uh
lately this unprovoked bishop to a4
seems to be
the way uh for white to seek advantage
and okay bishop to a4 you will prepare
c4 you will be able to tag the back the
bishop the c2 also control the d5 square
so knight to f6 and now just castles uh
offering the e for pawn uh however if
you go after the pawn with knight
captures on e4 it is possible but
then uh you y just gets a lot of
development in rookie one knight goes
back you can go d4
and so on and black still has to do a
whole lot
to just finish development so it's not a
good idea to go after it
we have a6 preparing b5 and now c4
stopping b5 and also grabbing more
control of the d5 square
we have g6 preparing to fianchetto the
dark square bishop and now
knight to c3 we have bishop to g7 and
h3 now so just nicely developing with
castles
and d3 a nice close position we have
rook to b8
now preparing b5 once again and rook to
b1
not worried about that and there is one
game where knight a couple of games
actually were knights to e8 was played
here but here we have queen to a5
and it is already as of move 10 that we
have a completely new game
uh so here are nakamura continues
development bishop to d2
now okay it's uh it's not a very uh
pleasant for black to
constantly be facing some discoveries
although there aren't any discoveries
for the moment like
if knight d5 you can just go back with
the queen but duda
goes back queen to c7 and you might
think but why not queen to c7 right away
well
by going queen to a5 back to c7 now
white has a
bishop on d2 which is not the most ideal
square if
black didn't go for this maneuver then
white could have
developed the bishop anywhere else so a3
nakamura prepares b4
and e6 now we have b4
uh b6 again just depending on c5 and now
b
captures in c5 with b captures on c5 and
queen c2 so if rook captures on b1 you
can recapture with the rook
we have knight to b6 going after the
bishop and bishop back to b3
knight after d7 and uh now comes
knight to a4 offering a trade of knights
and to do the declines we have knight
back to a8
uh saying that uh okay i'm very
satisfied with the position i don't want
to trade anything off too
too early and i still have to you know
uh keep uh keep a steady position as uh
i i i
i i really have to do well in this game
so bishop the c3 nakamura offers a trade
of
dark square bishops which uh do the
ghost for we have captures captures uh
but
with the knight not with the queen so
knight captures on c3 and now duda goes
back knight a to b6
uh we have queen to d2 now the dark
squares have been weakened and nakamura
wants to go queen to h6 followed by
knight g5 to threaten some checkmate on
h7
and so on so bishop to b7 developing the
bishop connecting rooks it's a very nice
diagonal for the dark
light for a bishop and the queen to h6
now
not not anything to be worried about a
dude that just goes rook after d8
makes room for the knight on f8 so you
can defend the h7 pawn
but nakamura still goes for a knight g5
and knight to f8 now defending queen
captures an h7
so f4 now with ideas of busting open the
position with f5
however f6 by uh duda kicking back the
knight and now also the queen has
control of the seventh rank so knight to
f3
and now bishop to c6 opening up the
the b file for the row could do that
wants to play rook b7 will be a double
up on the b
file and do some trades there and he
does have excellent control of the
center here as
as you can see really a lot of control
uh
so queen to h4 nakamura puts pressure on
the f6 pawn
and now comes queen to g7 defending and
now rook f2 e1
uh we rook to d7 now uh doubling up this
way
and the queen to f2 here nakamura
prepares d4 to
start his expansion in the center we
have rook d to b7
now you have to be careful for example
you can't really move the knight or
anything
uh there could be some some tactics when
the knight moves
off of winning the bishop or even if the
bishop and knight move just through
captures on d1 so you have to be careful
nakamura goes bishop the a2 just opens
up the b file for his rook
and now f5 by duda we have d4
as planned and now f captures on e4 we
have knight captures on e4
and now knight to a4 putting pressure on
the rook on b1 so nakamura trades once
uh rook captures rook captures and now
the question is can you grab the d6 pawn
uh well the answer is no because if you
capture on b6 then just rogue b2 and the
white is lost you lose the bishop here
there is not not much to be done here uh
or uh if you if you block with the rook
for example rookie two then just uh rook
captures uh
you you the queen will recapture you
will capture with the bishop bishop
captures an f3
and now it doesn't matter if the queen
or the pawn captures it for example if
queen captures an f3 then just queen
captures on d4 with
check will pick up the knight on d6 so
it is not okay to capture on v6 so
instead nakamura finds a brilliant
tactical idea
d5 and it just uh
asks black what do you want to do so
here
rook to b2 it is the strongest move
again attacking the queen putting
pressure on the bishop but now queen to
h4
saying that okay if you capture my
bishop i'm just going to capture d
captures on c6 and have a very nice past
pawn
so first do the traits once e captures
on d5 but now
knight f6 check we have king to h8 and
now comes c captures on d5 again with
the same idea if you capture i'm just
going to create a nice pass pawn on c6
so here uh bishop to b5 and we reach the
position from the thumbnail where
nakamura's bishop is trapped on
on a2 and unless you want to play
something like bishop to b1
uh you don't really have a good move
here or do you
uh feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the the brilliant tactical
idea
nakamura found while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the bishop is guarding the e8 square and
you really want to play rook to e8 so
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's
bishop to c4 you give up the bishop this
way
and it's not uh it's not easy to to
decline this sacrifice
for example if you just continue let's
say queen f7 uh then
white's idea is just to eliminate the
bishop and after eight captures now you
go knight to e8 and there is no defense
against
rook to e7 uh whatever you play let's
say c4 you're just going to go rook to
e7
queen has to move queen f5 and now queen
h6 there's no stopping queen g7 mate
or rather there is but you would have to
suffer severe material loss
so after bishop to c4 do the decides
okay i'm just going to capture
and see what happens there's not much to
be said here
or done uh so rook to e8 this was the
idea as the bishop
is no longer on b5 guarding the e8
square
now the thread is just rook captures uh
on f8 uh a queen cap
queen will recapture and then queen to
h7 will be checkmate
so h5 not allowing this and now knight
to d7 now just putting pressure on the
knight here the knight cannot capture as
it's pinned
and if queen captures on d7 nakamura had
a queen to f6
check in mine king h7 and now rook
captures an f8 and there's no defense
against uh
just rook h8 mate uh or rather you can
you can prolong it a little bit let's
say queen g7 but now
just uh check king h6 check and here we
have a nice checkmate once again
so after knight d7 uh do the played
bishop captures on d5
but it doesn't really make a difference
it will capture snf8 uh
bishop the g8 blocking check and now
just uh queen
uh to d8 uh and it was in this position
that young sister duda resigned the game
uh as there is nothing more to be done
here uh black has no counter play you
can just play knight f6 capture on g8
and
that's that's it there's there's no
defending this
so uh as uh black is getting checkmated
of course the duda resigned and uh
so i don't forget uh here are the
standings after three days of the lindor
savvy rapid challenge
there we have it the guys in golden it's
a it's a cross table from chess 24
website uh so the guys in golden are the
ones who proceed to the knockout phase
of the tournament
and the grishok ferruccia young shirt of
dude and the way he
uh are out of the tournament uh dub of
aaron and grishok have the
uh all three have five and a half points
uh but it wasn't enough and nakamura in
so lead with seven and a half points
uh i i believe without a single loss but
uh i'm not completely sure
uh and here are the the pairings for the
knockout phase of the tournament also uh
from the chest 24 website
uh there you have it nakamura will face
11 magnus will face wesley so yu yankee
will face ding and daniel dubo will face
off
against sergey karakin so it's a
one one event where we will definitely
not be seeing nakamura and carlson in
the finals as both of them
uh if they win in round one can only be
meet in semifinals and we will
definitely have someone else in the
in the finals uh so it's uh you know
most of the times you will have two of
them in the finals but not in this
particular tournament
uh so yeah that's uh the game i do hope
you enjoyed it and all the
all the tactical uh frenzy uh i would
like to thank uh
uh jacob cantrap epstein's mother
alexander coleman
robert kiefer and uh uh jos
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the lindoris abby
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
do join the tournaments the links are in
the description below
see you soon